what is the take-home message of the
show so to speak
what is the story that that Bearden is
telling us what is the story that that
the show is telling us in the particular
juxtapositions that that we see and
there's a lot of answer that could go
with that but but one answer that I want
to suggest that you think about as you
go through the show it may not meet the
eye right away is that whereas the
odyssey is so substantially a story of
men and whereas a big third of the story
the beginning is all about Odysseus's
son and his finding his way Bearden
flips things and makes this a story
where it's one woman's story after
another it's the story about powerful
women or shapeshifters and who are
people who can make things happen I grew
up in Washington DC on 7th and Taylor
Street and there was a kid on our street
whose name was Odyssey Lane this was
during the period of the very strict
segregation where in Washington you knew
where you lived because of color you
were and so I didn't see white people
passing by now and then through the
neighborhood and to me it's very moving
that mr. Lane who cut hair for a living
and this Lane was a housewife
saw this little thin leg girl as Odyssey
they looked at her this little brown
skinned child female and saw a world
traveler and potential heroic person a
savior in the in the in the imagery that
we see a next door
more than homer this is a story about
identity James Baldwin and Ellison and
others have said this is the American
question who are we what what what are
we how can we hold all the different
parts of ourselves together a Bearden
raises the question by making every
single character in the in his version
of the odd
as black as he can get them to say here
they are and and it's as if to say he
wants his viewers white and black to see
as mr. mrs. Lane did a whole world in
these black figures he wants you to
reach outside yourself and identify with
somebody who may be quite different from
yourself and see a world there he said
he wanted to make sure that his black
viewers African and African American and
others saw themselves on the story but
there's something else to where he's
warning others to participate and see
themselves in a story that's not
necessarily bears in terms of skin color
why did he make all the characters black
well did you see the Greek vases in the
met where they give the flat black
characters there they are so he's
talking about race but he's also saying
hey it's not always only about that it's
it's it's about choosing ancestors
beyond the usual lines so okay Harlem
Charlotte I choose Homer I choose
Matisse
I choose Africa I choose Asia I choose
as many sources as I can to to do what I
am what is my identity my identity as
we've heard already a citizen of the
world I take what I need to make myself
bigger and more magnanimous and generous
in my personal culture as I go forward I
think the show asks us to do is to think
about form it's a translation and so
what can visually
that a poem can't do what does seeing it
in this way
what do that seeing it on the page
doesn't quite do in the same way nothing
like the same way I asked Tony Morrison
about something like this that was at
one point I said you do Cersei and
Bearden does Cersei and what's the
difference and she said you know yeah I
can do a lot on a page you know I can
tell and she was like I'm Toni Morrison
but she said
but then she said something I'll never
forget she said but by the time Romy
took out that knife of his and started
slashing at the paper he could do things
I couldn't do so there's a fierceness in
those collages there's a directness you
can see the edge of the scissors and the
knife in the work that that makes you
think about what collage and what visual
art can do that other forms can't do
when he's working on the Iliad series
those pen and ink I think we might ask
ourselves what can you do in pen and ink
and he does he's Sargent
Bearden home from from the war and he's
slashing it that paper thinking about
war and perhaps how useless and terrible
and costly and worth it in some ways but
damn it not worth it in others
that's slashing there I think it's just
something incredible so think about the
fact that we're looking at the pen and
inks from the 40s when you do that
you'll see the watercolors and I think
you'll be reminded of the fact that he's
peace he's depicting a very watery tale
that this Odyssey he's thinking about
the baptism that's why that's in the
show and how water can save you you can
drown in the water as well beside this
is the king of the water so he'll swim
right through there and kill everybody
as he because he surely does except for
the one that the sister saves so he's
thinking about water and water color
sometimes the waters running off the
page they come after the collages so
it's interesting to think first I'm
drawing with scissors and now I'm
drawing in a in a medium that's less
forgiving I can't go back and and put
another piece on top you got sort of one
time through it's a very different
medium so think about media or mediums
one might say as you're going through
and finally these collages that the
master works of the show that's why
they're given the big room because all
the space that they need and their I
think the question is identity again how
can I cut pieces that are Asian and put
them next to the ones that are obviously
European and African and show how
layered we are as a community
as individual people sometimes write
about beard and say oh the fractured
black community Bearden saw this as a
layered complicated set of people they
are part this and they're part that
they're African we know that Africans
but they also live here so long they're
part of the Native American
of Europe or America we adopt these
different cultures living in the place
that we live in and nothing says that
quite like collage that we that we are
that we are constructed people we can
tear things away and add a little
something else and and I think that's
part of it that the message here in
conclusion I would say please walk
around and see the Dutch masters and see
the Chinese calligraphy and see the
African iconography Egyptian and
otherwise I see the beanie right next
door to the Matisse and you'll be seeing
things I think with the kind of
expansive vision that that Bearden
himself FC Circe as a power figure also
a woman of the blues is not she sad all
the time she's say like Bessie was
saying you know she been through a lot
of trouble and survived at all and had
lived to tell about it
and finally you think about sister
Odyssey Lane and and I wonder where she
is now the and and this idea of seeing
and somebody as different from oneself
as you can imagine this possibility of a
world traveler who might just dive down
and save everybody thank you very much